breast cancer kills tens of thousands of
women in this country
every year but black women face a much
greater risk of dying from the disease
in today's buddy check 8 report i talked
with a local specialist about a growing
concern from doctors
who warn the disparity may get worse
[Music]
this year many women postpone their
annual mammogram
and that puts african americans at even
greater risk
since they're more likely to be
diagnosed with breast cancer at
later stages of the disease they also
face more burdens at
every step of their journey the other
problem is just
awareness sometimes because of the lack
of
access and what some might call
institutional racism
there is not the
ability to get in
and see the physicians or nurse
practitioners the providers as fast as
one should
dr russell gallard medical director at
optum care cancer center
points out that black women are at
particularly higher risk
of developing the most aggressive breast
cancer triple negative
triple negative disease is in many ways
its own entity and has a very very
high rate of coming back even
after initial surgery and chemotherapy
dr gallard says studying genetics and
biology of breast cancer could go
a long way to saving women of color
there aren't many
genetic uh
in the state of nevada we're lucky
enough to
have one working with us here but but
yes
getting the appropriate testing and
seeing somebody
who can actually order that testing
interpret it
and you know i will say this it's not
only important for the individuals who
are getting
tested but for their family members so
besides biology
regular screenings are so important to
catching cancer early
and experts recommend you need to do
that monthly breast self exam to detect
any changes in your body
and we'll be right back